The endocrine glands, the testicles or ovaries, the pancreas, the adrenal, thyroid, and parathyroid glands.
Their job? To secrete hormones.
The most important one of all is the hypothesis.
It measures only one centimeter in diameter, but is nevertheless the conductor of the orchestra.
However, it does depend on the hypothalamus, which is right in the middle of the brain.
It receives the messages sent by the nervous system and coordinates its function with that of the endocrine system.
They play an important part in influencing both the individual organs and the body as a whole.
For example, adrenaline, which is manufactured by the adrenal glands, is the hormone which keeps you on the alert.
Its job is to speed things up, to dilate the vessels of the muscles you're using so that the whole body is better irrigated.
To stimulate the heart, to mobilize the sugars that feed the body and make it less tired,
to dilate the pupils and the bronchi, and to help us through periods of stress.
What is happening, eh?
Wait a minute, I want you to tell me why you were fiddling in my beard.
I, uh, was working, maestro.
Fiddling in my beard, though?
Yes, indeed. Hard at work I was.
All right, I'll forgive you this time, but hadn't you better answer the telephone?
Hello?
Hello? Yes, this is the hypothalamus exchange. Good morning to you.
What are you waiting for? Would you make a note of the messages?
Very well, all right, at once.
Immediate secretion of TSH hormones in order to stimulate the thyroid gland,
in order to make the metabolism speed up.
The game has just begun and I think it's going to be a long one.
Activate the alpha cells in the pancreas for the secretion of glucagon.
The muscles need some fuel and the sugar reserves must therefore be freed.
Those are all hormones, aren't they? But we're in the hypothalamus, we're part of the brain.
We don't make hormones, do we?
Look, my friend, we in the brain's control room coordinate everything and transmit commands.
Where to, though?
There.
There?
No half-wit under my foot.
To the floor below, down there to the hypothesis.
Oh, I see, down there, is it?
No.
It's enough up there, quiet!
What's going on up there?
Those hormones, of course.
It's always those awful hormones.
Well, TSH, responsible for stimulating the thyroid gland, you'd have to go that way, please.
plates. TSH hormones on their way from the hypothesis to the thyroid gland. Tell it to
manufacture other messengers whose task it will be to activate the production of energy.
Who's that? Same thing. Call them relay hormones if you like. Relay hormones did you say? Yes,
that sounds good. Make us work as hard as this for that? Quite right, Phil. It's absolutely inhuman.
Furnaces heaven? Don't get anywhere at all with that lot. You are. We're out of sugar again.
now there's almost no oxygen left they won't listen to us it's hardly worthwhile asking us
for energy if they're not going to give us anything at all with which to make the energy
i'm absolutely sure it'll arrive soon the sugar reserves are nearly full same with the oxygen as
well they assure me they have lots it just takes time to go and fetch all of it can't keep this up
the fly is going out my little files of iodine you're my consolation and my support and you give
me so much joy you know the thyroid gland is the biggest the only in fact the unique reserve of
iodine in the body and it belongs to me why have you come to spy on me huh is this the iodine store
wants to know well you see we've brought you some new supplies sir i think it's iodine oh well done
oh very well done all this lovely iodine and it's mine all mine responsible for it please sit over
there lovely hey wait please do as i say you're not taking any are you taking any what sir iodine
of course show me your hands come on show me they're empty look there's nothing what about
the others huh no nothing right then you show me your hands well let me put this in the treasury
old scrooge the iodine treasury of is he a bit cuckoo a bit he's completely bonkers that old
chap he seems to think that he owns all that precious iodine a plague on all misers and
miserliness i say ah my iodine my dear my beautiful iodine see i've got inexhaustible supplies here
here inexhaustible i tell you microgram marvelous two of them no three micrograms fantastic
what shall we do grab it and say thanks a lot not going to like that iodine reserves are there
That'll be used, aren't they? What else are they there for?
You know, he likes to look at them and rearrange them and count them and then he locks them up.
I'd prefer if you go and tell him.
No, no, no, you must go.
All right, you two, this iodine that we need for making the hormones, have you got it or not?
My little files of iodine, my precious reserves, you're not going to take them from me, are you?
But Mr. Scrooge, Mr. Keeper, the iodine reserves are there to be utilized when necessary.
But I've hardly got any reserves left. Iodine's very scarce these days.
You wouldn't like to come back another time, would you?
I'm sorry, but that was a command. I have to follow my orders, and they're very urgent, too.
But are they really very urgent?
Well, why don't you look for yourself?
But they have...
What? No, no, no.
After this, the thyroid must make hormones urgently to speed up the supply of energy.
No, no, no. No!
Iodine reserves immediately.
Precious!
Iodine, that's...
We must have justice, good heavens.
I'm lost.
I've been murdered.
They've cut my throat, taken all the...
What's going to happen to it?
Where is it?
Where is it hidden?
How am I going to find it?
Where shall I run to?
Maybe here.
There.
Maybe it's over here.
Stop.
Give me my iodine, you fool, you awful fool, you.
It's your silver.
I'm in really a bad way.
An idiot.
A real simple Simonton.
They don't make him look at it anymore.
I'm lost.
The iodine store.
The iodine store, yes, I'm in charge.
Look, they've taken everything. There's nothing left. Well, almost nothing.
What will become of me, I ask you? No more iodine, I tell you, so push off.
This, I've brought you a few bottles.
Oh, goody! You've brought some iodine. That gives me so much joy.
I'm going to rebuild my treasure bit by bit.
But, but wait! There's very little in here, very little indeed. Is that all I've got?
Are you sure?
Thyroid hormone.
Thyroid has been well informed. Here are all it diced messages.
TH hormones are on their way, but I'm also going to need some glucagon hormones to release
the sugars in the liver.
First, throw some adrenaline to stimulate the nervous system and the heart.
All set adrenaline, come along, come along, adrenal glands get to work.
The most energetic and powerful of all the hormones!
Are you all ready?
23.
Relate the heart to be our job, you see.
It must get up to 120 beats a minute.
So, let's go.
120 beats a minute, you say?
Watch out, he might get overtired.
We need more oxygen, right?
Well, the oxygen looks fine.
And is the sugar coming?
I'll take you, it's because I-
You two think this is the time for chit-chat?
Get to the pancreas on the double.
It's very urgent, hurry!
Reserves?
Yes!
Absolutely urgent, urgent, urgent.
Destination is the factories of the liver and their reserves of sugar.
Right, glucagon hormones!
Come to release the reserves of sugar into the blood.
Please let us in.
Mm-hmm.
The salt, the salt, the salt.
We're to respect the right of way and don't.
I don't understand anymore, Lieutenant.
I just don't know what's got into them.
It's because the body's working really hard.
The metabolism has been speeded up by all the circulation of hormones.
Just look at them.
See what I mean?
Got some fuel here.
We've come to start making some energy, you see.
Let's get going.
One bag of sugar, six bubbles of oxygen.
Energy seems to be building up.
Good.
Have a look.
Where are the reserves?
No more sugar.
and to get the fats moving will take time.
And the hearts.
Huh?
130 beats a minute and no supplies?
130, that's crazy, that's exhaustion.
No good, no good at all.
I'm exhausted.
One can't even get rid of the carbon dioxide.
Oxygen.
Always more oxygen.
I can't take it anymore.
That's Red Corpuscle's job.
And even if it's not much fun,
we have to do our best as always.
Look.
Hello, everybody.
Friends down there look exhausted.
Well, that's because the whole body's extremely tired.
Our enemies, the germs, would like that, wouldn't they?
They would, Lieutenant.
The breathing's so rapid that the dust particles might break through the protective barrier.
We'd better keep check.
Calm down.
We are going to need your help for a little while.
About some nice pneumonia, even though the bronchi are quite far away.
It's follow the circulation.
That'll get us there soon enough.
But that's dangerous.
The body's well protected.
But very tired, too, and we can multiply on our way.
Okay, guys, there are no cops around.
Let's get going. Follow me.
Simply don't exist.
Oh, yes, we do, and here we are.
Bodies' defenses aren't up to standard.
Diplococcus bacteria, Lieutenant.
In their thousands, I think we'd better split up and fast.
We don't have enough energy anymore.
The antibodies, because that's all we have.
We have only one way of beating this infection,
and that's with outside help, by using antibiotics.
But call in our own reinforcements anyway.
Attention. Attention all.
The bronchial infected by Diplococcus bacteria.
onset of pneumonia but he's a big strong boy we'll fix him he'll be fine how on earth did he get it
well he overdid things and to cope with the situation the hormones had to release all the
reserves when these were all used up and the defense is exhausted the germs invaded the body
but luckily we do have antibiotics when can i have my tennis revenge
hahaha